Democratic presidential hopeful Peabody
judges snagged some key establishment
support three former Obama officials
including former aide and special
assistant Reggie love have thrown their
support behind the South Bend mayor in a
statement love set in part a lot of what
is said about Pete echoes critics said
about Barack Obama
I believe there's never a better time to
fight for change than right now
hilarious
faith endorsements come just days after
Vice President Joe Biden accused Budaj
of stealing his health care proposal but
will these endorsements actually hurt
Joe Biden are they going to help them
joining us now via Skype to weigh in is
David Pakman host of the David Pakman
show and friend of our show great Caesar
thank you
all right so what do you make of these
endorsements Reggie love that's a funny
one coming for Pete Budaj and how they
may affect the race yeah I think this is
super safe for the establishment so if
you step back and understand the
establishment centrists even a lot of
corporate legacy media they want to deny
Bernie Sanders and to a degree Elizabeth
Warren the nomination so you might think
by by starting to endorse or support
someone that seems like an alternative
to Joe Biden you might be splitting the
vote you might actually be be hurting
the establishment and helping Elizabeth
Warren or Bernie Sanders but I don't
think that's the case I think that this
is a strategy based around the reality
that the more Joe Biden is in public the
worse it is for him after every debate
his polling drops so it's very safe for
the establishment to say let's support
someone who is an alternative to Joe
Biden ideologically but once you pull
someone sort of into the universe of
centrism
if they say you know I like butta judges
ideas but I find him to be inexperienced
or too young or whatever it's a very
natural transition to say well I guess
I'll go with Biden after all and you're
sort of excluding the universe in which
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
exist so I think it's it's a it's
actually possibly a good strategy for an
establishment that wants to deny Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren the
nomination and and why do you think that
they've settled upon this basically in
order to keep Budaj alive for now they
know he's probably not going to get the
nomination he has absolutely zero
support amongst the black vote
in South Carolina and in some of the
other some of the other Super Tuesday
states that they'll eventually be able
to coalesce around Biden once that
happens that's exactly right I think
that is and interestingly the first few
primaries of caucus and primary Iowa and
New Hampshire you don't necessarily need
black support to do well in those and
Pete Budaj is doing well there and once
you get people into the minds general
ideology of Budaj edge can at least win
some primaries again even if he
ultimately fails once you get to Nevada
and certainly in South Carolina based on
the way the polls are looking right now
the argument for saying well let's
implore one if you've been propping up
someone like butta judge all really
interestingly in the last democratic
debate in November we plotted polling
support at the time remember Buddha
judge was not doing as well in the polls
at the time we plotted polling support
with speaking time Buddha judge was the
candidate who by far got much more
speaking time than his polling at the
time would would predict right and the
reason for that is becoming very clear
as you see all these endorsements roll
in but you know I think that they have
considered the notion that Elizabeth
Warren could win I don't think they even
considered the idea that Bernie Sanders
could win I mean you had Hillary Clinton
on with Howard Stern I'm sure he
listened to some of the at least some of
the key experts as we did with her
talking about how disappointed she was
that he didn't endorse her faster
leaving out the fact that of course he
went out and campaigned for her all over
the place he probably could mean harder
for her than she campaigned for herself
and yet she's still blaming him for the
loss but never in that whole diatribe
did she even like contemplate the idea
that he could be the nominee her whole
focus was I just hope he endorses the
eventual nominee which would most
definitely not be him once that time
comes well not only that we've also
covered on my program that Elizabeth
Warren although she has said many times
she's closest to Bernie ideologically in
the Senate she said nothing during the
2016 primary so the so actually if
Clinton wanted to ask questions about
the timing of endorsements back in 2016
she could have said you know III think
that actually Elizabeth Warren is
someone who whose motives could be
questioned even though it went in a way
that was favorable favorable to Hillary
Clinton in the end so I think the
questioning of motives and timing is not
necessarily a good path for Hillary
Clinton to go down but you see the you
know some people are calling it a Bernie
blackout you see the what seems to be
the coincidental but maybe actually
strategic exclusion of Bernie Sanders
from a lot of the discussions around
polling around Budaj edge versus Biden
and and at this point it's impossible to
say that it's an accident he's literally
number two it's just crazy I mean he
literally would think he that he didn't
exist we're gonna cover it later but
there was a PBS Newshour special I think
what was at fifteen thirty thirty
minutes and they didn't mention him
whatsoever I mean I just think for the
person who moved regardless of you know
whatever they think of him he moved the
Democratic primary the Overton Window on
so many different issues so dramatically
in such a short period of time what do
you think you what do you think that
that it's owed to is that they just
can't understand it is it strategic
we're trying to dive into it here I
think it's a combination of all of the
above and the sad part is that this
stuff does work and I've read a few
interesting pieces that examine is
polling support following media coverage
does media coverage react to polling
support I mean at some point it's a sort
of chicken-egg thing but what's very
clear is that the polling support that
has diminished for Bernie at least
nationally over the last few weeks is
only being reinforced by the fact that
he is being ignored so I actually think
the the question of which is causing
which is less relevant than the
realization that like this is happening
and if you're concerned about someone
being left out in in perpetuity then it
doesn't really matter figuring out
whether the cause the cause or the
effect is the decrease in polling it's a
red-alert problem that is a type of
interference in the primary yeah well
and it's interesting what you say about
Pete because I hadn't really thought
about this before but let's say he wins
I
he's very non-threatening to to Joe
Biden in particular because he had so
little support in the african-american
community in particular or in the Latino
community for that matter he has so
little support he's not gonna go much
further than you know doing well in Iowa
maybe doing well in New Hampshire
so it's non-threatening but it keeps
someone like Bernie Sanders now if he
were to win both Iowa and New Hampshire
then you got a real ballgame on your
hands because not only does he have a
base of working class multiracial
working class support he also is number
two
for Joe Biden supporters and number two
for a lot of older African Americans who
if they were looking to switch he would
be the logical person to go to yet what
this is what a lot of people maybe are
ignoring Donald Trump has correctly said
okay I lost to Hillary by three million
votes but had it been a popular vote
election I would have run the entire
thing differently yeah the same analysis
applies to the primary which is if every
state voted on the same day the way that
the establishment would try to deny
Bernie or Warren the primary would be a
different strategy in this particular
case if you can deny Bernie or Warren a
win in Iowa a win in New Hampshire and
it goes to Budaj
even though it seems like Budaj and
Biden are more in a direct competition
once you get to the dais where many
states vote if Joe Biden remains in the
lead and and cleans up in a lot of those
you win by having denied Bernie or
Warren momentum early on in those early
States that's very interesting and
thought about it very well said David
great to see you David thank you guys
next up on rising labor protests
continue raging in Paris France as
citizens share their opposition to
proposed pension plan cuts economist
professor Richard wolf explains what
those alterations would be and the
latest us economic news when rising
continues